[Music]
why did y'all get separated um
mainly because of his drinking
and i know that you know what i'm about
to say
okay
you're trying to keep a fantasy alive
and you have to let it go your kids are
bearing the brunt of this
[Music]
rattata what's up this is john with dr
john dolone's show glad to see you
and if i can't see you i'm glad to
be the voice in between your head it's
probably not good for both of us but i'm
glad to be there i hope you're doing
well hope your family's doing well on
this show we talk about mental health
relationships being well mental wellness
this is the best mental health podcast
ever ever
and um i've got six people who've dm to
me and told me that so that data works
for me i like statistics that back up
what i already think um hashtag america
and so it's good to see everybody if you
want to be on the show give me a call
1-844-693-3291-184-693-3291 or go to
johndhelony.comask
and hey quick shout out so one of my
best friends on the planet guy named
trevor moore
and we were in dallas recently and we
lived in the dorm together and had all
kind of shenanigans um dude his kids
came out to the book signing
his son elliot dude drew me this
incredible picture
of spider-man and hulk
and he wrote this is me and dr john
we're both wearing texas ranger hats
because they know that i don't like the
rangers i'm an astros fan awesome and
then his daughter poppy wrote this
incredible
lovely card she drew pictures in it have
good luck with your book so excited to
see you today proud of your book love
poppy dude there's nothing cooler than
seeing somebody that
i don't maybe i didn't make great
decisions when i was around when we were
kids and now they've got kids and
they're raising great humans and i think
america we're gonna be all right we're
gonna be all right if those of us who
didn't make good choices are raising
people who made good choices make good
choices
we're going to be all right all right
let's go to codeman let's go to cody in
atlanta georgia what's up cody
hey how are you i'm good hey remember
that time um
the astros were gonna get to win the
world series and y'all ruined everything
remember that
yeah we finally won something here in
atlanta well i hope that was fun for you
it was not for me so what's up man
hey so um i'm i'm 25 i live in uh
atlanta um and then my girlfriend she's
26 and she was in new york city
um she just got her uh masters in acting
actually this week so
mfa
yeah mfa very cool where was she at
school in new york
yeah she uh she moved to new york about
three years ago to do that so you all
hung in there long distance for three
years huh
oh no so we she came back during the
summer and um to see your family and
stuff and we met at the coffee shop that
i work at um
and so we did three months together here
in the summer and then we've done the
past eight months um uh okay all right
so about a year and you all met at the
coffee shop whoa
is that it it's a candy shop that's the
candy shop song not the coffee shop song
the coffee shop song is the is the
boring slow version the card
coffee shop whoa all right so um y'all
been together about a year and then what
um so originally we planned on me moving
up to new york um around this time
uh because you know i do coffee and i do
live sound so i was like i can get a job
anywhere and she wants to do
um
theater and acting and you know a place
to be that's for theater that's right
and
new york is where dreams are made of
right
yeah absolutely there you go i sound
just like alicia keys on that one i'm
pretty sure okay so i keep interrupting
you go ahead go ahead
no you're fine you're fine um but uh
you know i i recently found um
you know the dave ramsey stuff i started
getting into that and trying to get a
hold of my finances and i just don't see
feasibly how both of us can live in new
york when we're in the entertainment
stuff and just uh it's just costs so
much to live there yeah it's wild man um
and so i mean i told her i was like i
just can't do that and also at the same
time i've been getting a lot of good
opportunities here
uh
in georgia with doing sound which is
what i went to school for so i've been
getting a lot of good opportunities with
letting corporate stuff and just
churches in the area
and there's a lot there's a lot of
entertainment stuff moving to atlanta
it's fast tracking to atlanta which is
just it's an incredible i remember back
in you know i was i was in houston most
of my childhood in
all my childhood and i remember when
austin started
blowing up they called started calling
the third coast right people started
moving it and i feel like atlanta is
there too like there's just some
incredible opportunities there which is
great man good deal absolutely so um
ultimately what's your question yeah so
um she she eventually was
not eventually that's terrible she also
saw that she couldn't do that so she's
moving back home and
you know we've just been long distance
for so long and
i'm just scared we're not scared like we
have fears but i'm just trying to figure
out what is fears versus what are the
red flags when it comes to our
relationships
hmm
is there has to be a
difference i don't know
um so a red flag for me is something
that violates one of my core values
or um
probably initial red flag is gonna is
gonna violate what i believe to be one
of my beliefs and then what i'm going to
do is i'm going to dig in on that red
flag and see if my belief is what i
thought it was if it's if it's a
make or break belief you know what i
mean like me and my wife have voted
differently at times great that's
awesome um we have different opinions on
theology sometimes we have we have
different opinions on a lot of stuff
especially on music she thinks my
music's awful
um and so
but those are beliefs right and when i
was 25 if you had told me i was married
by then but if i was 24 let's say and i
wasn't married
i just have a rule if you didn't like
the show seinfeld i just knew we weren't
going to be friends
right so if someone's like i don't i'm
not into that show i just i wouldn't
even continue not trying to be a jerk i
just know where this ends and this ends
with me making a joke that's a little
bit sarcastic can you get your feelings
hurt and we're not gonna be friends
my wife is the first seinfeld uh person
who didn't like seinfeld that i ended up
remaining friends with and then now
we've got a family and a couple of
decades of history so all i have to tell
you is a red flag is something that
initially violates a belief of mine and
ultimately would come down to a
a red light if you will would be a this
violates a value of mine
um
you want to continue to hook up with
other people and that's not somebody
that i want to date right or whatever
what i can come up with a million
different things a fear would just be
uncomfortable right
a fear would be your body telling you
hey this is a risk
is this worth the risk
and
that's that's a that's an equation that
only you can answer really right
okay yeah so so are you are you guys
fighting are you all having
disagreements
where is your is your is your like your
that feeling in your guts where's that
coming from
yeah so um i mean
she said something that i didn't you
know it took me a second to process um
but like she said that she feels like
we'll never move out of georgia because
i'll always have an excuse to
stay here in georgia okay
i'm like yeah i mean like
i don't hate it here
you know i've lived here my whole life
and then it just kind of felt like it
was like
she's always going to be upset with me
for not wanting to move if opportunities
come up or i'll find an excuse
and so probably the truth is
yes and yes
is that fair
so only only example i can give you is
from my personal life i come from the
city and i moved out to a west texas
town that was a smaller city
and the moment i landed there i started
plotting my exit
i have to get out of here my body can't
live here i don't want to be here and
then my wife um who's my girlfriend at
the time said
this guy will get me out of here like i
don't really think he's that attractive
and he's a humongous head and he puts
too much product in his hair and he
listens to annoying music he'll get me
out of here right so she hits your wagon
and
we ended up living in that community for
between 15 to 20 years and it was where
our closest friends are and then there
came a moment when it was time to go and
we knew that and it was it's been great
and she said i just you know she laughed
because i just played the long game
here's what i'm telling you
are we ever going to leave here or i
don't see my future in georgia or i
those are all great valid conversations
those are great and valid disagreements
things to you know
talk on the front end
if somebody looked at me and i've got
friends like this
i will never move away from the town
that my parents live in full stop
that would be a
a i need to i need to examine that can i
live in this community forever because
you're being very clear with me i will
never want to have kids
going into this relationship we're
shaking hands on this are we all on the
same page so in five years and you say i
really want kids i'm gonna say i told
you as a you know what i mean
so um
it sounds to me like
she is falling for you
and
is trying to come up with with reasons
why
um you don't want to
she's trying to think 15 years down the
road or five years down the road or 10
years down the road and come up with
with future reasons and project them
into the now and it sounds like you're
doing the same thing
and what i would tell you is
both of you say yes if we have great
opportunities here it's great and if
something cool comes up i'm absolutely
open to hearing that unless you're not
and if you say i will never leave
georgia and i grew up in texas there was
texans it did they they be unemployed
fighting war it doesn't matter i will
never leave texas good for you just make
that clear to the person you're going to
marry does that make sense
absolutely
are you pushing her away
um
no i think
it was just like you know for so long we
talked about being in new york and then
now it's flipped to her now moving
here so i think she just got scared of
me like
it's like all kind of recent yeah
what i want you to do i've got um good
one
i want you guys to
have a funeral service for the dream of
new york together
and i want y'all to grieve that
it's going to suck
because y'all had started making plans
about this life and you were going to
run a coffee shop and you were also
going to start running sounds for big
shows and she was going to be on
broadway and it's not dead trust me it's
not dead it will happen but right now
there's just a dot-dot-dot after it and
it feels like you'll have failed that
you have lost something and you didn't
lose anything other than a dream
and if you don't grieve this thing and
sit on it what the the grief will make
its way into well i told you this and
you never want to do that that's how
it'll end up it'll come out and you'll
end up in fights about things that are
just proxy wars for
i'm really sad that we built this
picture together and it didn't come true
because it's too expensive to live there
if you all will grieve it and be able to
go
we wanted to do this and it didn't
happen yet
it didn't happen right now
and your wife your wife your girlfriend
was to read a letter about how sad she
was and here's what she wanted to do
about it here's her dreams and they're
not coming true right now and here's her
fears and you read your dreams and your
fears and you'll read them together and
then you can set that stuff down and
then what you can do is say okay for the
next year
let's build a
awesome relationship here in georgia
let's put some let's let's look at how
can we make georgia as awesome as
possible for one year let's just do that
and let's love each other and let's date
and let's get serious and let's have fun
and let's build one year and then we're
going to reevaluate we'll put on the
calendar we'll commit to in one year
we're going to circle back and say how
is this year see what i'm saying and
don't don't have
problems 15 years down the road or 10
years down the road that aren't really
gonna materialize yet okay unless you
know in your soul i will never leave
jordan and if that's the case tell her
that a part of being in relationship and
loving me is never leaving georgia and i
would tell you
don't do that
don't do that
there's a big big world out there man
and love's a really cool thing and um it
will take you to
all corners of the earth right um but
don't
don't get into is this fear this red
flag dude just jump in jump in and say
this hurts what can we build next but
that's a man that is a great great
question cody thank you for asking that
man
um
i don't know for whatever reason maybe
i'm just in a good mood today i feel
really good about where you are headed
it's awesome right we all need to be
we'll be right back
good people dr john deloney here and i
know we all want to feel better mentally
physically emotionally and i mean think
about the goals you've set the diets
you've started the workouts you've tried
the routines you've adjusted to change
for the better but despite all that
effort you're probably overlooking one
of the easiest changes you can make
that's guaranteed to help you out
get in good sleep trust me seven to nine
hours of quality sleep every night will
change your life for the better and
quality sleep starts with a quality
mattress and that's why i love
dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses are
made with advanced technologies that
keep you comfortable all night long and
right now dream cloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners when you order a mattress you
now get 499 dollars in sleep accessories
like pillows a mattress protector and
luxury sheets plus an additional 250
cash discount for john de loni show
listeners that's a total of 749 dollars
in accessories and savings if it's time
to change your sleep for the better
visit dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress today
all right troublemakers we're back let's
go to elizabeth in cleveland oh
what's up elizabeth
hey doctor john thank you so much for
taking my call thank you so much for
calling what's up
yeah i'm curious and excuse me i'm
coming out after a cold so if you can't
hear me let me know but
um i'm curious to hear your perspective
on the difference between
what some would consider a biblical call
to live a life of sacrifice and then
also self-sabotage
tell me more
yeah so
i was part of
um just christian ministry work for
a number of years and since then i
opened up my own for-profit business
that doesn't have a religious
affiliation with it
um and i think my mindset when i was
doing the
ministry work and then my mindset now is
just very different
right now i'm very interested in just
becoming a responsible steward over
the people i'm overseeing and
the things that i'm overseeing
and sometimes it feels a little
like
self-focused and sometimes it feels like
the more that i
help for myself to be a sustainable
person it is getting me off track from
where
i felt very alive and very
in step with with my beliefs in the lord
and and with my relationship with the
lord and so now i'm just
curious where that where you would say
that balance would be
because even when i look back at what i
was doing
when i was doing my ministry work
some of it felt you know
very off-the-cuff keep moving you know
good things but also kind of like i know
i wasn't setting my people up well back
there right and like i know i wasn't
being a responsible steward of all of
these things so yeah now that i'm in
this jump of you know healing process
from
a lot of things and
um i'm just kind of
curious as to what you think that that
balance is or what that looks like
that's a great great question so there's
there's four or five different angles we
can take here um
let me get one more piece of data from
you so yeah um
give me an example of a couple of things
you were doing that you would classify
under quote unquote
ministry um so things that i was doing
a lot of it was dance ministry so i
would be
leader or choreographer or
prayer leader etc
and we would
do performances in a number of different
settings whether it was a prayer meeting
or sometimes during some services
but then we also took that overseas
and we
did similar things just met with people
talked with people
very little sleep
um because you know we were just trying
to put
the people in each other first and just
you know time with the lord um
and
what does time with the lord mean
time with the lord like reading the
bible and praying and things like that
reading the bible praying
yeah
excuse me i guess just at that time i
had just more regular conversation with
the lord like more thoughts that
um
were
in that connection
whereas now a lot of my thoughts and a
lot of my practices are like oh what can
i do
oh how can i fix this god does that make
sense yeah yeah totally
so
um he's a great theologian he's a
songwriter he's most famous for his
songwriting i think he
um in a hundred years will be more
memory remembered for his
um theology
uh rich mullins
and rich mullins said something that
deeply affected me 15 or 20 years ago
and he said
be weary of anybody or anything
that says that divides this is my
occupation and this is my ministry
right because we tend to if you are a
person of faith and you have a
quote-unquote ministry
you
wrap up
and you segment in your life
quote unquote ministry e things
in your world that was artistic
expression that was
prayer time that was uh reading
important text or scripture or or
whatever books you were reading having
those type of thoughts right
and
now you're in your quote unquote job and
you're trying to run a business and
you're trying to make payroll and you're
trying to make sure that ding ding-dong
shows up on time and that person doesn't
say the things and this person's got a
504 accommodation and i got to deal with
an angry customer
and so what i would challenge you on is
this
i don't believe
that ministry
is
doing jesusy things
i think ministry is honoring people
right here's a great another great quote
rich mullin says he tells a story of the
time he was hanging out with some
missionaries overseas
and um he was hanging out with the
missionaries and one of the missionaries
he one missionary says man what's on
your mind and he said nothing i just
feel so overwhelmed with joy and love
for god
and i just want god to use me however he
needs me
and he said the missionary started
laughing
and he said my brother
god does not need you for anything
nothing
tree people will
and so i would challenge all people of
faith
that ministry is flushing the toilet
ministry is tipping well ministries
letting somebody in at the stoplight
even though they're driving like a [ __ ]
ministry is taking care of homeless
people and hungry people ministry is how
i treat an angry customer
right right and so what i would suggest
is the work you are doing you are in a
position
to do infinitely
more quote-unquote ministry service to
people
where you are right now
that's that's the statement number one
statement number two is
there is a true
i don't like i don't like business i
miss art i miss dance i miss travel
and that's a occupational question you
have to ask yourself
what often we get messy is we try to
we believe that if you're a person of
faith and you believe in god that the
language i hear about calling and
passion and purpose as though god hid
that from you like an easter egg and
your whole life is like trying to find
it you know what i mean like i just got
to find my calling i had to find my
passion no dude like
i'm trying to run a business i don't i
don't like it i'm not this isn't for me
i don't like it or i'm running a
business and there's just parts of it i
don't like and there's probably parts of
dance that you don't like in parts of
the travel and parts of being exhausted
so it's really
what do i want to do
and more importantly who am i going to
be while i'm doing it
right that makes sense and so i would
love to see you look at your business is
your business successful are you doing
good stuff
i mean we're trying to
i mean ultimately i would say yes
so we're you know still trying to get
back in it but i think that's also the
challenge is you know when i opened this
business i had it with that foresight of
this is just another expression of of
ministry and yet now that i'm you know
about five years in
it's just
i don't know i think it feels like
like the way that i yeah i don't know
can i tell you a hard truth is what it
sounds like yeah sounds like you're
blaming the business
and i would love to see you reverse
engineer who you want to be with your
faith community and who you want to be
in relationship to god
and start there yeah and if you are in
sync with your um spiritual life and if
you're in sync with god and you're in
sync with
trying to honor people and love people
the best you can every single step of
the way
that all of that goes into how you're
going to quote unquote lead your
business or deal with a troubled
supplier or honor somebody who you did
we had on this show we had a sponsor
and it just didn't work out um it just
didn't fit
and
we called and gave some of their money
back
and we actually canceled the contract
then we gave
that never happens
and
even the the business owner reached out
and said that never happens
[Music]
we feel so grateful and in my head it
was we're just doing right by you you
know what i'm saying
and so
good business backs up to being a good
human a good human backs up for me to my
faith community and my spiritual
principles right in my relationship to
god so
um all that to say is
it sounds like you're found yourself
exhausted after five years especially
the last 24 months of just trying to
survive
and it feels like you are distant from
who you remember being in a former life
which part of that's a
fantasy too
and now you're looking for why and it's
easy to point fingers at the at the
business i would love to see you look in
the mirror and say what look at my daily
practices what is it about my life that
has become disconnected from my
spiritual beliefs is that fair
yeah very much so thank you so much oh
you betcha um listen
if it makes you if this is any
any consolation you're right where you
should be
thanks like you're not crazy is that
fair
that's
very good to hear you're not you're not
you're not nuts and if you decide next
month to just quit your business and go
back and find a ministry to work for
that's not a bad thing
yeah
if you decide to get a coach and sit
down and say here's who i want to be are
you married
i am okay have you all sat down and said
who we want to be
yeah so we're in the process of that
we've been married about a year and so
we're just starting and my lease is
coming up with the business
okay
a lot of those big conversations um so
do me a favor don't start with should we
close the business
that's the wrong place to start
we should start is we're one year in
let's do a how'd the year go
what did we learn what was hard what was
weird what was different than we thought
and you'll have to be honest with one
another and have it be a no pressure
a low pressure you know i mean
i want to just tell you i thought
hooking up with you is going to be one
way it's super different than i thought
i thought that laundry was going to look
different and like like let's talk about
what it was
and then let's the the next part of
conversation is who do we want to be
together
right and then we're going to backfill
what that business looks like
okay if you start with should we close
the business that's going to be made
with a lot of emotion and a lot of
feeling and a lot of emotions and
feelings are exhaustion right now right
because you've been trying to be married
too and try to run a business and you're
exhausted and trying to stay alive and
all of a sudden your spiritual life has
taken a back seat and now you feel you
see what i'm saying how it just runs
that way have a low pressure who do we
want to be together we want to tour that
we don't travel the world well it's
probably not gonna be good to run a
business then we need to do something
else
we want to make a whole bunch of money
so we can give away a hilarious amount
of money that's incredible great we're
gonna have to come up with a great
business that serves our local and
national community
in a way that honors them as we're known
for good business practices and makes us
a great salary so that we can give stuff
away
all those are
great holy endeavors it is a matter of
setting that identity and just working
backwards is that cool yes i would i
would be really honored if you would
have that meeting
and either you and or you and your
husband call back and say here's how
that went
here's how the meeting went i would love
to hear how that thing goes
it's one of my favorite conversations to
have with my wife and one of the
conversations i avoided for about a
decade of being married which is who do
we want to be and then how do we get
there
that how do we get there clarifies
things that we're going to do but more
importantly it clarifies things we're
not going to do
and that's hard for me because i like to
go do stuff i don't like to not do stuff
but that setting that identity up front
really clarifies my actions both
affirmative what i'm going to do
love it love it elizabeth you're right
where you need to be
take care we'll see you soon we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right kids let's go to harrisburg
pennsylvania and talk to samantha what's
up samantha
hi dr john how are you speak with you
i'm good how are you remarkable we are
rocking on to the break of dawn what's
up
okay so um
i am currently separated from my husband
for about three years we have two
children together and i recently found
out that he got a dui
um
so i'm just wondering
how
or if i should talk to the kids about
this
boundaries i should set how old are the
kids
15 and 12. well almost 16 she's turning
16 next month
so my first question is why in the world
are y'all separated but not divorced
well
the one
thing that's keeping us married right
now is insurance i carry the health
insurance and
um
just trying to
you know
give that to him for now um instead of
adding an extra expense why did you like
this
mainly because of his drinking
can i tell you some real hard truth is
that okay
yes okay and i know that you know what
i'm about to say
okay
you're trying to keep a fantasy alive
and you have to let it go
you love this guy
possibly more than he loves himself
and he's also dangerous and he has hurt
you correct
yes okay
you made a choice for your safety to
leave
whether that's physical safety emotional
safety psychological whatever you made a
choice to go
but what you're doing is you're you're
suffocating everybody
and you're not letting people go
and so the idea that did you leave him
yes do you have some deep guilt over
that
um
i do
because
um i kept the house
and he he moved out
um so i kind of have i have guilt with
that and
you know he still
you know says i'm the one that you know
that
did this and
made this choice and you know so i do
i do carry that it feels like you were
trying to
pacify or
band-aid over your guilt by saying but
at least i give him health insurance
i've kicked him out
he's created his own life
but at least i still provide him health
insurance
yeah pretty much and sam i'm never gonna
you've heard me say this um
if you're an abusive situation i would
tell you something told you you have to
leave you got to get out of there
and you left but only part way and if
you're going to be gone after three
years you gotta go
your kids are
bearing the brunt of this
okay and i know that's hard to say and
it's hard to hear i'm a dad too that's
the worst thing i could possibly hear
but your kids are continuing this
fantasy
that mom and dad are still married
they're just lived separately and still
and your husband's drinking is clearly
still not in control and now he's
putting your kids lives at risk because
they get to go see him is that right
well
they only really see him about once a
week for a few hours
okay that will begin to change as they
get older
unless there's some sort of
okay let me just cut to it did he ever
hurt you
no so why'd you leave did he cheat on
you
no
um i just couldn't take the drinking
anymore and he was getting
a little verbally abusive calling me
names just being mean
towards me um and i just you know we
were fighting all the time and i didn't
want i didn't want the kids to continue
to live in that situation right
and and i i think that's a wise choice
i'm not for one second going to say that
wasn't a good choice um do you have
desires to be married to him
no i have
i am
grieving the loss of what i thought my
life would be there you go
but i
him
being the person who he is right now i i
do not wish to be with him no okay the
way you just said that suggests but
maybe one day he'll not be that person
that he is and then it will all work out
and you're trying to you're trying to
have a foot in both worlds and you can't
do that
because you're you're asking this 15
year old and this 12 year old to have
feats in both world 2 and they can't do
that
you can you can't do that and i'll tell
you even you're making yourself insane
you know that you are right
a little yeah you're running two
households and you're parenting him too
oh i could just go and i don't want to
beat you up i'm just telling you you've
got to make a decision
i'm going to be married with this guy
and we're gonna go to therapy i'm gonna
try to figure this out and he's gonna
decide to stop drinking and stop being
unsafe
and
i think that ship has failed
then you've got to move on with your
life
yeah for your sake for his sake you're
dragging him through this he still
thinks there's a chance this comes back
together
if he got completely sober today went
stone sober went to aaa every day for 30
days got clean came back to you would
you have him back
um
i don't know that's a good question
maybe
i don't know i think there's uh there's
a lot of hurt and resentment
um with both of us so i'm not sure if if
that would even be enough at this point
somehow you've drawn a line in your
house between kicking him out and
getting divorced where does that line
come from because it's been three years
i know
um you have an imaginary line between
that this is this is not great but it's
okay but if i cross this line i'm done
for
and i would tell here's what i tell you
you've crossed that line you're way past
that line
yeah
and so
what you've done now is put yourself in
an unsafe position because you were
still illegally bound to this person
yeah kids are still legally bound to
this person who is demonstrating again
with what third dui he's unsafe
yeah
and he clearly needs help and support
and i love the guy
that's i think the greatest gift you
could give him is to cut him lose
yeah you're right and i would say this
for 30 days if you were having a 30-day
separation i think those are important
sometimes or a sick we've been apart for
six months and we're still going to
therapy this isn't that this is you've
been divorced for three years you've
just never gone through the process
right
right yeah
and here's another thing if you called
me and said
hey this happened three years and then
my husband's been clean for four months
and i still love him i would say go all
in i'd be all for that obviously do it
safely and all that but it doesn't sound
like it's gonna happen
yeah no
no he doesn't think he has a problem
okay
and so
we that that exceeds the scope of this
call what i would tell you is you've got
to at some point start making some plans
okay
if to answer your original question
i would not have if i felt it unsafe
to be with somebody
i would i would feel this especially
that that about my kids
yeah okay
that's the way i would look at that
problem if people get divorced because
such and such cheated on me um i still
think people can be good great parents
there i think you figured that out you
co-parent or we just fight a lot
whatever we just have different values
people get divorced for a million
different reasons
if somebody leaves a home because that
person's unsafe
then i'm gonna go to the map for my kids
too
yeah you know what i mean
yes and i think that's partially why i
do not
push the issue of him having the
children more
um because i just
i'm not sure if that's the best for them
tell me say that statement again but
tell me truthfully
you said i'm i'm i'm not so sure that
that's the best for them tell me the
truth on that statement
um
[Music]
you're not sure what you know that it's
not safe for them
yeah
you know that
somebody told you a long time ago that
what you think and feel and believe
doesn't matter and i'm telling you it
does
and living with an alcoholic that's
often you're crazy you're ridiculous
you're not seeing things yeah right
oh yeah
all the time did you grow up with an
alcoholic too
no this is all new
yes okay
well i mean he's had a problem ever
since we were together
okay
um
i just thought he would
grow out of it
you were going to fix him that was so
kind of you
think that way yes
exactly and then it's like oh i know it
will help let's have a baby and it's
like oh i know what happened help two
babies
yes
yes yeah
and here you find yourself i'm
heartbroken for you i'm heartbroken for
him i hope i hope hope hope he gets the
help that he needs he deserves that and
those kids deserve their dad
um
based on what i'm looking at right here
he doesn't sound safe
he doesn't sound safe
um and you've put yourself in a
situation your kid's in a situation and
him in a situation that's untenable
just this this kind of half in half out
fantasy life
i'm not i i can go through my day and
never have to say the words i'm divorced
um i get to say that it's just kind of
it's bordering on disingenuous at this
point
yeah
and that might mean you have to sell the
house and split equity all those all
that ugliness right that's part of legal
separation but i would suggest that's
part of the decision you made when you
decided to move out through your kick
him out three years ago not that it's a
wrong decision that just that decision
comes with consequence like all
decisions happen right
right and so it's time to get with a
good counselor and a good lawyer and
start having those hard conversations or
to sit down with him and say where are
we what's the status of our relationship
does he still have fantasies about
getting back with you
i i don't think so okay why isn't he
filed on you because health insurance
yeah i mean really the insurance is like
the main thing he has already signed
over the house to me um
really the only thing yeah it's just an
extra expense that he doesn't
want to have right now what's the equity
accumulated in that home
oh
probably
60 000.
oh that's it
yeah okay
okay so we just gave it to you
yeah
so yeah i mean you do what you want to
do i i would not um if i was in this
situation and i had been married to
somebody who was struggling with alcohol
abuse and alcohol addiction and they
have a history of duis and they got yet
another one it would be um less about do
i tell the kids and all that it would be
my kids will not be dad's struggling
dad's not dead sick he's struggling
and um
uh
we're not gonna get in the car with that
eyes the parent i'm not gonna allow that
i'm not gonna allow it and if he's
unsafe at home too you're not gonna just
can't be there when he's drinking which
is all the time now so we're just not
gonna go over there yeah the best they
don't typically go over this house okay
the best way forward there is a court
outlining those
protections
okay because right now he's their dad
and he's still your husband and so there
are still some
at any moment he comes in and says now
those are my kids
and i can have them whenever i want them
and you would say no you can't and he'd
be like
who says who
right
yeah that's where the court really helps
define
because the court says i say so
when it comes to child safety
okay all of this breaks my heart sam i'm
sorry
thank you
i know it's the worst do you have
somebody you have somebody with you i
know and this is how you drew it up
right you didn't want to be like this
you didn't want your kids to come from a
divorced family right
absolutely not i know that stinks man
i'm sorry
sorry
thank you
yeah
your values and beliefs and feelings
count they matter
they're important
and thank you
yeah good luck with what comes next it's
gonna be hey listen make no mistake it's
gonna be hard the next few steps are
gonna be hard they're actually gonna be
harder than you think and they're gonna
be easier in some other ways
um
that's tough that's tough that's tough
yeah get on the counselor and get with
an attorney soon and let's dig into
what's next we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back hey in in honor of
today's show we're gonna do two best
songs of all time uh we're gonna do them
really fast though the first one
empire state of mind by the great
jerusalem featuring alisa keys and it
goes like this now i'm out of that
brooklyn now i'm down in tribeca right
next to de niro but i'll be hood forever
i'm the new sinatra and since i made it
here i can make it anywhere yeah they
love me everywhere i used to cop in
harlem holla like dominicans de niro
right there up on broadway brought me
back to that mcdonald's took it to my
stash bought 560
street catch me in the kitchen like a
simmons whip and pastry and
john mayer's why georgia
why i'm driving up 85 and the kind of
morning that lasts all afternoon just
stuck inside the gloom four more exits
to my apartment but i'm tempted to keep
the car and drive and leave it all
behind that's why she wants to leave
georgia cause why
why georgia
why
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode it's man i
the last probably six seven years i'm
just done like i i sometimes i i throw
my key in the ignition and i i'm going
into work and i see the case that i'm
assigned i'm just like i don't want to
do this anymore your exhaustion is well
earned
and your body's been through the ringer
and you're a guy that holds it all
together for everybody in june 2020 uh i
attempted
you know i i was in the hospital due to
her attempt to suicide but that happened
and you know my mom
she already struggled with depression
and she just
it made it so much worse and hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
you didn't make it so much worse
you didn't